well the united nations says it's
increasingly alarmed about the plight of
our eritrean civilians caught up in the
conflict in ethiopia
the un refugee agency says it's received
disturbing reports
of displaced people being killed or
kidnapped and forcibly returned
to eritrea which borders ethiopia's
battle-scarred
tigrai region the first international
aid convoy has arrived in tigris since
fighting broke out there more than a
month ago
well let's go to the ethiopian capital
addis ababa to journalist
samuel getachew hi samuel now an aid
convoy has arrived but getting
information from tigre
is proving difficult what do we know
about the current situation there
we know for a fact that the areas that
can be
accessible to the un and its partners
are
only areas controlled by the federal
government the ethiopian governments
so much of the area is still not
accessible to the u.n
uh there are many many thousands of
people including eritrean refugees
that are in desperate need according to
the united nations as of last night
they've run out of all kinds of things
including basic food
so you can only imagine the kind of
humanitarian disaster that's going on
in the region definitely incredibly
concerning that the u.n
says it's concerned about reports of
eritrean refugees in the ethiopian
region being killed
or abducted or forcibly returned to
eritrea
what have the what is the actual
ethiopian government being saying though
the ethiopian government side insists
eritrea and soldiers
are not taking part in any of the
conflicts
there has been an ongoing accusations
including reports done by reuters
afp and bloomberg
saying that they are involved but the
government insists
no international player is involved in
this conflict and it's
they insist it's only the ethiopian
soldiers and ethiopian army
that is involved trying to liberate
trying to bring
some kind of freedom to the people of
chicago so um
everything we hear contradicts each
other but
again the conflict is ongoing and there
are many many people that are heading to
the sudan
and we're hearing of different stories
that's just heartbreaking
i'm sure i'm sure they are now you've
just been mentioning it there so
the ethiopian government says it's in
control of tigrai
and the conflict is isn't over or
they're saying it is over
but leaders of the tigre people's
liberation front say that they're still
fighting on various fronts what's your
assessment
there are segments of the tplf uh that
might not have the resources or manpower
or i should say person power but you
know
it's the the segment of the tplf that's
so passionate about uh
what they believe in you know many of
the population of tigra
are young people that have always known
tplf government
so it's uh you know the devil you know
that the devil you don't
so they're focused on trying to defeat
uh
uh the government or the army the
ethiopian army
so they're still fighting and we hear of
different stories
uh and when we hear victims that are
heading to the sudan
they tell us exactly the same thing
which is the conflict is ongoing
and there are many many victims that are
just dying
and people with little resources young
people all people being left behind
so it's a cash 22 but we know for
certain the conflict hasn't finished
only because even communication hasn't
been lifted in many parts of the region
so it's an ongoing conflict that we're
watching from a distance only because we
can't access it
as journalists well a journalist samuel
will get at you in addis ababa thanks
for that update
thank you
you